the duration of time that you're knocked
unconscious is a lot like the height of
bridges any who ever jumped off
a 20-foot Bridge says oh man it was 100
feet you know and anybody's ever been
knocked unconscious oh man it was five
minutes dude but you timed the book yeah
I specifically timed the ball and it was
like about a minute five seconds just
because I want to know right everybody
was saying that you were out for like
five minutes no that's not true it
probably feels like that when you're
like is he gonna wake back up if you're
knocked out you have no concept of time
right sure the only way to know for sure
is to go back and watch the footage
because my memory was erased for a
little bit what's the difference when
you pass out like snoring or not snoring
or snoring the doctor says you're trying
to swallow your tongue I snored with the
bull and I snored with butter bean yeah